you at least get this shot  man you not pay me enough for this leave  the channels blowing up that's all money  right there baby but you know we could  make more what if we turned this into a  show we do out looking for real monsters  attention all monsters in the Los  Angeles area looking for subjects to be  interviewed for a documentary titled the  March their partner  I don't think we should be going looking  for those things  we got another response to the casting  notice issues have been rising we all  love a good morning story we like to  pretend that monsters are real  the monster project scene 1 take 1  what if they truly exist living amongst  us I understand you wish to conceal your  identity for your protection  people that we brought here to interview  they're not people  [Music]  [Music]  you  you